PLAYING.
>> CHUCK, WHAT IS THAT MINUS
116, 102?
>> YOU HAVE TO BET A CERTAIN
AMOUNT TO GET A BET.
>> WE DON'T HOME BET BOY IN THE
CASINO.
IT DOESN'T MATTER ABOUT THE
JAMES HARDEN PLAYING.
MILWAUKEE BUCKS ARE GOING TO WIN
TONIGHT!
♪♪
>> OH, YES.
>> A PARTY!
>> IT'S A PARTY!
IT'S A PARTY!
>> THANK YOU!
>> THIS IS THE GREATEST THING!
>> COME ON IN.
>> BEST PLACE PLAT WORLD!
>> WOW!
>> MAN!
>> MICKEY!
>> THIS IS THE GREATEST BUTTON
IN THE WORLD!
>> YOU'RE WELCOME, CHUCK.
>> LET'S HAVE A DOUGHNUT EATING
CONTEST.
>> CHUCK, HIT IT AGAIN.
>> MIGHT NEED SOME MILK.
>> THIS IS THE GREATEST THING IN
THE WORLD IS KRISPY KREME
DOUGHNUTS!
>> HIT IT AGAIN, CHUCK!
>> OH, MY GOODNESS!
>> LOOK AT THE FACE.
>> KENNY, I THINK I'LL START MY
DIET TOMORROW!
>> MY DIET IS SHOT!
>> ONE DOUGHNUT AIN'T GOING TO
MAKE YOU OVERWEIGHT.
>> THAT IS GOOD, MAN!
>> WE ARE TAKING YOUR WORD ON
THAT?
>> IT WASN'T ONE DOUGHNUT THAT
GOT HIM LIKE THAT.
>> COME ON AND GET A DOUGHNUT,
BRO.
>> THERE WAS ONE DOUGHNUT AT A
TIME.
>> MY GOSH.
>> THIS IS THE GREATEST!
THANK YOU VERY MUCH!
MAN ALIVE!
>> LET ME EAT ONE MORE AND THEN
TAKE IT AWAY.
I CAN'T.
>> SOMEBODY TAKE THESE AWAY.
>> YOU CAN ONLY HAVE TWO.
>> THANK YOU.
IF I EAT ANY DURING HALFTIME, I
CAN GO HOME?
>> YOU E